martin biron michel c'est roger paul
journet bonsoir
alors où vous en êtes dans vos dans
votre analyse
de l'utilité vous avez vu ces images
quand même ces marches c'est
commentaires je disais de cette parole
qu'on attend davantage cette journée de
la vérité de la réconciliation martin on
va parler après la réaction mais sur le
fond mais d'abord tour de table sur
aujourd'hui l'utilité d'une journée
comme celle-là martin je trouve que
c'est extrêmement utile j'ai écouté
beaucoup de témoignages aujourd'hui j'ai
trouvé ça intéressant et la diversité de
ces témoignages là et ça fait longtemps
quand même que je couvre les affaires
autochtones à travers les époques un peu
partout ici dans l'ouest au québec la
crise autochtone du terrain et je me
rends compte que quand même eu des potes
géants qui ont été fait que les gens
sont beaucoup plus conscients de la
question autochtone c'est un dossier
complexe qui pas facile à comprendre
on comprend mieux tous les jours et les
langues se délient et on sent aussi que
les communautés autochtones commença le
lien de confiance est en train de
s'établir et les langues se délient et
c'est c'est bien de les en temps parce
que ça nous aide à mieux les aider à
mieux comprendre et
voilà je souligne trois fois ce que vous
venez de dire le lien de confiance qui
commence à s'établir aussi les des
autochtones face au gouvernement faso à
la société qu'ils voient ce qu'ils
voient être sincèrement touché par une
part des choses qui ont été
épouvantables chelsea
madame monet disaient les mots qu'on
attendait il ya 30 ans 4 serait d'écrire
des autochtones des alcooliques drogués
salle et c'est la société blanche a
changé par rapport à lass est une bonne
chose donc là on peut probablement à
cause de ce lien de confiance l'a
commencé à régler des problèmes entre
autres le territoire qui va être bien
compliqué long mais on peut penser qu'on
va le régler et avoir une fille et par
année pour penser à ces choses là si on
est capable d'un calendrier d'avoir une
journée pour la fête de la reine
victoria j'imagine que c'est cher c'est
assez important pour qu'on lui donne une
journée aussi parade et
l'importance de la journée est assez
facile à démontrer c'est qu'on est en
train d'être en parlait depuis plusieurs
minutes en ce moment et que l'éducation
puis la connaissance est important de
mon est encore très très loin de le même
si bon certains préjugés diminue perdent
un peu de leur intensité il ne meurt et
la méconnaissance est aussi encore très
grande pour toutes sortes de raisons
entre autres aussi parce que les médias
on est souvent dans les grands centres
urbains tout comme la majorité de la
population on est très loin des
différentes communautés des différentes
nations et même chez les personnes de
donc de bonne foi ils sont pas souvent
en contact avec des gens des premières
nations et aussi quand on parle de
réconciliation c'est un mot qui est
tellement immense qui donne presque le
vertige
je comprends que ça va peut-être prendre
une génération pour régler sa mort
seulement par où commencer
donc c'est important d'écouter puis
entre autres d'écouter le travail déjà
fait par toutes les commissions qui ont
pondu des rapports pour lesquels il ya
peut-être pas suffisamment eu de suite
inévitablement puis michel si vous
suivez la politique depuis assez
longtemps vous le savez inévitablement
on devra revenir à ce que jean chrétien
vous le faire quand il était jeune
ministre à ottawa c'est à dire
l'abolition de cette loi sur les indiens
est
programmée une relation entre les
nations autochtones et le canada et les
provinces mais on appris on n'a pas été
capable depuis de rides de de l'abolir
être capable de se mettre d'accord et
les autochtones
quand je parlais de responsables it and
shell audet partager les autochtones
c'est bon c'est bien beau si on enlève
la loi sur les indiens on devient et
dans une relation adulte avec telle
nation le fédéral les provinces mais on
veut pas tout perdre non plus alors là
ça va être complexe mais c'est pas
inévitable martin
chaque chose en son temps et c'est ça
que je réalise je pense que les plus
l'opinion publique prend conscience de
ce qu'est cette loi-là de où on s'en va
plus elles poussent vers
l entrée la rame avec les communautés
autochtones
ce qui n'était pas le cas avant c'était
ce dossier qui très difficile à
comprendre parce que bon par exemple
nous au québec on a vécu la crise
autochtone alors on ne te faut que
c'était sur la crise autochtone et après
90 les gens étaient assez amer à l'égard
des autochtones aujourd'hui les choses
ont évolué parce que d'autres
autochtones d'autres communautés ont
expliqué ce qu'ils ont vécu et c'est là
que tranquillement l'opinion publique
commence à mieux comprendre l'enjeu par
exemple des pensionnats commence à mieux
comprendre où on s'en va et elle va
ramer avec les autochtones et mettent la
pression elle même sur les gouvernements
pour que les choses changent très bien
monsieur legault dont qui a parlé de ça
et qui après s'est fait demander
à brûle pourpoint mais parce que le
congé férié ce n'est la plupart des
provinces et grosses 3 ne l'ont pas
adopté la salle fédéral et il quelques
provinces la nouvelle écosse
la saskatchewan le manitoba manitoba
nouvelle écosse bon bref écoutez ça
écoutez ce que ça a produit comme
réaction sur
ce qui est arrivé entre des pensionnats
ses terres et puis on tour ça sonne et
un chaque année c'est bon qu'on a une
journée de commémoration
et que le premier ministre le go soit
incapable de quelques empathie que ce
soit envers tous ces gens là c'est en
tant que québécois sam ça me sidère et
je souhaite que mon premier ministre du
québec soit capable à l'avenir de foudre
de faire preuve de beaucoup plus
d'impact et de compréhension envers les
peuples autochtones du québec et de
partout au pays ben on l'a entendu plus
tôt dans l'émission de ce logo est
revenu à dix a expliqué qu'on ne pouvait
pas ajouter un congé férié comme ça que
c'est très bon mais ce qui a été perçu
sur le coup puis ça a été envoyée puis
vous savez avec les réseaux de sa vie
c'est un manque de sensibilité qu'en
pensez vous martin et à québec d'abord
mais en fait je vais je dire deux choses
parce que d'abord il ya deux façons de
le voir si on regarde l'arbre c'est sûr
que les réactions ont été très vives des
parties de pollution ou six qui ont
souligné le manque de sensibilité c'est
la deuxième fois dans la semaine que
monsieur legault manque
de sensibilité à ce qui a trait à la
question autochtone au début de la
semaine c'était la période des questions
lorsqu on commémorait le décès de joyce
et chaque wayne mais quand on se regarde
la forêt en entier on se rend compte que
monsieur legault il ya quelque chose qui
cloche avec monsieur legault liepa très
focus depuis le début de la session et
monsieur legault si quelqu'un qui se
prépare beaucoup et le vus pendant la
crise da pandémie on voyait que choisit
ses mots mais quand on écoute
attentivement la séquence quand il était
dans le corridor s'était pas préparé ce
qui le dit alors qu'est ce qui se passe
avec monsieur legault il ya une file
dans son équipe dans ses proches
conseillers et quelque chose qui cloche
ça c'est clair une chaîne
de choses là-dessus d'abord
la grande force de monsieur legault en
plus d'être quelqu'un de sympathique et
les c'était d'avoir de leur père si
justement et là ils étaient tous
chauffard pratique d'y répondre comme
comptable dans on a besoin de plus de
productivité pas de notre journée de
congé step est la bonne réponse
aujourd'hui mais pas demain donc ça
c'est la première des choses la deuxième
c'est quand on a vu monsieur guilbeault
il ya un coup de coude bienvenue dans la
ligue nationale
voici le nouveau ton des relations
fédérales-provinciales à partir de 30
ans les élections sont pas les élections
sont passées et ça n'a pas passé comme
dans du beurre d'affaires d' d'appuyer
monsieur autour il ya des choses qu'il
ya des choses qui vont changer
inévitable c'est comme si monsieur
guilbeault même cherche un micro la
pierre ce genre de relation phrase là on
n'aurait pas entendu chaudun mineuse
fédéral libéral compte monsieur legault
la tue on les sent qu'il n'y a rien qui
voit qu'on va laisser passer paul sur
l'île de java c on dirait qu'elle est la
vengeance est un plat qui se mange chaud
et fraîchement sorti du four
est un peu exagéré de la part de
monsieur guilbeault est-il québec c'est
pas la seule province qui en prépare un
congé férié donc vous l'avez dit
l'ontario l'alberta puis à certains
égards je crois aussi le nouveau
brunswick halle donc je pense pas que la
chose à faire en cette journée de la
réconciliation c'est de poursuivre les
guéguerres politiciennes
cela dit je note que monsieur legault
souvenez vous à la fin de la dernière
session parlementaire il promettait
d'être un peu plus zen c'est pas très
bien parti c'est ça le problème cette
semaine sont éteints d'accumulation puis
de réactions à chaud oui manque un peu
de hauteur je convaincre l'opposition le
picoche depuis longtemps voulant faire
un débat sur le thème racisme cité mais
au lieu d'un autre terme mais hier c'est
la journée pour répondre à l'opposition
mais prendre prétexte de leurs questions
pour s'adresser aux premières nations si
c'est un peu on pense cette semaine mais
c'est un but qu'on devrait parler pour
les utiliser comme prétexte pour
prolonger les guerres partisanes après
on le sent tendu marthien dans le champ
dans une logique
quasi électorale avec le québec
solidaire avec les libéraux et qui a été
absent cette semaine paul le diffère un
peu de hauteur en fait on a l'impression
de loin j'ai comme un égard noble mais
si ça au lieu de mettre son son chapeau
de premier ministre et parce que c'est
sûr que les partis d'opposition veulent
se démarquer le chemin pour y aller
alors c'est sûr que les questions et les
réactions sont toujours empreintes de
beaucoup de partisanerie mais monsieur
legault un devoir que les autres n'ont
pas ce à dire que là il devait mettre
son chapeau de deux premiers ministres
pour ses gants de boxe le chef de la caq
et c'est ce qui a fait et aujourd'hui on
le sentait comme un peu essoufflée parce
que les questions autochtones de
préoccupe monsieur le groupe du pion
aussi qui est beaucoup plus à l'aise
avec les questions opérateurs de terrain
mais la question autochtone quand joyce
et chacun est décédé il ya un an il y a
pris le taureau par les cornes il savait
politiquement qu'il devait faire quelque
chose a changé son ministre il ya dix
ans on va mettre en place le rapport
vient ça va peut-être pas au rythme que
certains voudraient que ça il met quand
même
il fait des pas pour que cette question
là avance ici que c'est important alors
aujourd'hui il n'était pas sur son os x
n'était pas à la bonne place
et aussi joli tracé n'oublions pas il
changé de position sur le projet appui
ou appuya d'éoliennes avec les
communautés avec toutes les communautés
y nous donc il a essayé de progresser
mais dans ce pot sa meilleure semaine
auxquelles monsieur dubé qui veut que
bon il annoncé conviendront pas là tu le
centre bell et salles de spectacles de
ce monde vont pouvoir être remplie à
craquer mais avec le masque c'est réglé
mais là messieurs du pays veut que les
députés donnent l'exemple que le
passeport vaccinale soit obligatoire
martin chez vous dans les corridors de
l'assemblée nationale député personnel
tout en les côtes ce qu'on demande à
tout le monde je comprends pas
honnêtement nous devons arrêter ma
réponse là je comprends pas que les
parlementaires ne veulent pas donner
d'exemple aux québécois je pense que
c'est beaucoup plus une décision
politique d'une décision de santé
publique pense qu'on devrait donner
l'exemple et assez de gens au québec
sont forcées depuis un an et demi pour
pop colline parlementaire frais paul les
foires de donner l'exemple québécois
pourquoi ça passe passe à un paul
d'après vous parce que y en a d'autres
qui ont des réserves de montrer
l'exemple justement quand exigeante
parfois vaccinale je cherche sans
trouver pourquoi ça ne passe pas parce
que monsieur dubé je trouve à raison au
delà des grands calculs de santé
publique y aussi des décisions
politiques et symboliques qui devraient
être prises puis au moment où cet
automne on demande au personnel soignant
d'avoir ces deux doses et aussi où on
songe à le faire pour les enseignants ce
qui serait une bonne idée me semble-t-il
c'est la moindre des choses que
l'assemblée nationale s'impose là même
la même contrainte jeu cette finale est
libre martin québec solidaire et quand
le pq aussi le pq et quand les libéraux
sont pour mais puis le pq s10 bastille
la maison du peuple alors le peuple
devrait avoir accès à sa maison comme il
le veut mais n'a pas accès le pet n'a
pas accès actuellement tu peux pas
entrer s'est invité les gradins à la
période des questions sont au vide les
l'école commission parlementaire seuls
les invités peuvent y assister il ya
aucun peuple et à 200 alors pas ce
concept du vice à la ga sidiki et moi je
dis aux gens je reçois des jours sur des
bêtises à cause du patient avec nadal et
restera en aidant là tu donner l'exemple
à l'assemblée nationale ouais c'est la
friction entre la santé publique et le
politique parce que vous avez vu horacio
arruda qui disait moi je me suis pas
prononcé le dessus alors le pour québec
solidaire ils ont bougé dix balles et
nous on écoute la science moi même j'ai
dit il ya aussi un côté sanitaire là
dedans je dis si on décide que les gens
peuvent revenir
si le forum d'assilah centre bell peut
être plaît pourquoi l'assemblée
nationale mais il faut pas contaminer
parlementaire donc les gens
qui vient veulent aller voir une séance
de l'assemblée nationale où une
commission parlementaire devrait pouvoir
montrer l'emplacement vaccinale sans
trop de problème je vois pas la
difficulté majeure de sow puis je vois
pas dans le jeu démocratique
je n'en parlerai aux guitares
l'opposition elle aussi des fois parler
d'elle un demande auteurs oui de
l'opposition vous et ouais là tu
avais raison par les gi joe 2 difficile
à suivre il faut noter qu horacio arruda
a dit aujourd'hui que l'automne se passe
beaucoup mieux qu'il ne l'avait lui même
prévu paul donc c'est intéressant sur la
tue
mais je pense pas que c'est un lien
direct le
met en effet si c'est ça explique aussi
pourquoi monsieur dubé c'est un peu un
commence à parler à une heure où le port
du masque ne serait peut-être plus
requis par tous mais bon il faudra voir
les fêtes et le prochain rendez vous
c'est la vaccination des 5 à 11 ans qui
pourrait commencez espère-t-on début
novembre on reste à voir quel
pourcentage de gens seront vaccinés quel
serait l'effet mais ses prochains rendez
vous prochain rendez-vous pour moi ce
sera ce sera
merci beaucoup à vous trois
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit